hi everyone uh thanks for joining my
talk I'm Dean as baritha said and I'm
going to be talking about a machine
learning and production and specifically
what production even means
um so to get started let's talk about
buzzwords uh who doesn't like them they
make us uh sound smart they allow us to
convey a lot of information with a
single or few words but they also
introduce inferential distance which
means that the things that you take for
granted people have not yet learned and
they can be confusing now this isn't to
say that buzzwords are inherently bad
even though the term sometimes does
evoke a negative sentiment they can be
dangerous however they give us the
feeling that we understand something
without always being able to really
explain it in simple terms and
specifically I want to talk about uh one
buzzword that I took for granted which
is production
so I want to start with a story I was
giving a different talk about applying
machine learning in practice and
covering a bunch of things related to
mlops and I shared the obvious notion
that machine learning models are not
just for research maybe not even mostly
for research and then I asked the
audience what I thought was a very
simple question which is if you create a
really great model but no one uses it or
in other words it's not deployed to
production does it really matter
and I thought that this would be a great
rhetorical question to get started with
my talk but one of the listeners raised
their hand and asked when you say
production what exactly do you mean and
I found myself noticing this
International inferential distance I was
talking about earlier I was treating
something vague that seemed clear to me
as a given and asking questions about it
when in fact many data scientists or or
in the audience might have a different
notion of what production is or they
don't really understand what I'm talking
about and that is how this talk came to
be
um so back to our question let me ask
you again if you create a great model
but no one uses it does it really matter
now applying a first principles approach
let's try to define the the term
production in the context of machine
learning models so I would argue that
putting a machine learning model in
production means that your machine
learning models predictions or outputs
directly affect some product or user
whether it's by educating them helping
them make decisions or enabling them to
do something that they couldn't before
for example creating uh sort of Van Gogh
style Shakespearean meme for the purpose
of this talk so all of the images here
that aren't icons were created by stable
diffusion
um and to add a bit more context right
there was this famous statistic about 87
of models not making it to production
and this statistic is probably incorrect
but my interpretation of the sentence is
that a large part of machine learning
models never make it to the point where
they actually have an effect on any
products or users or consumers
and so you might ask at this point why
should you care right
um and I think that there are
um for a lot of people that are new to
the field but even in the case that you
are an advanced practitioner right
um hearing the vague term production
thrown around but not really
understanding what it means so I'm going
to try to fix that right
the other thing is
um I'm we're going to see what lies
behind a certain buzzword but even if
production is sort of clear to you but
you have some other buzzword maybe
feature store or Active Learning
um and you kind of sort of but not
really understand it so I'm going to try
to show you how to deconstruct these
ideas and rebuild them from the ground
up so that they might be uh so this
might be widely applicable and not just
to production
and last but not least I'm going to try
to provide a first principles approach
to thinking about model deployment what
challenges you need to solve and showing
you the first steps you need to take in
solving them
great so now that we've defined
production for models we can ask another
question
um what types of production are there
and the easy answer here is to go
straight to the various ways in which we
can deploy a model which is indeed a
form of production and we'll dive into
it in a moment but it's important to
note that it is not the only way to
deploy a model uh to production and as a
preparation for this talk I asked the
kind people of Reddit what production
looks like for their team and I got many
interesting answers so the easy one is
that for many of them it was actually
deploying a model endpoint and in this
case the the deployment might be done as
a Lambda function or some other uh
solution but it might also be that
they're building the model into an
application that runs on an edge device
whether it's your mobile phone is part
of an app or a car if you're building an
autonomous vehicle
another thing that is totally different
so for some they run the model locally
on a regular Cadence and then they
upload the predictions as a table to a
database which is queried by different
consumers within the organization
um one specific form of this is that
your sort of model is an internal means
to an end so some people shared that
their production is basically a
dashboard that they send out to
management that uses machine learning
models to create some of the information
within it that still counts right
um and then last but not least it might
be that your model is part of a larger
uh uh ETL pipeline that uh sort of
creates just a single feature in other
words your model might be just another
part of a pipeline and I think this last
point is worth diving into
so when we think about machine learning
we usually imagine a machine learning
model which is some black box with
potentially weird math magic happening
inside it that receives data and spits
out some prediction of cat or dog right
and while this might be how production
looks like for some people from our
experience and most times this is an
oversimplification of reality and in
most cases reality is usually more
complicated so I would argue that this
is a better model for real life so
you're trying to deploy a pipeline right
and this pipeline can include
etls it can include multiple models
um and and so the the model prediction
is de facto a form of data
transformation and you need to ensure
that the pre and post-processing steps
are probably deployed to production and
so in some rare cases your model will
receive data and return a prediction but
in many others you're going to need to
add custom processing before and or
after to have a real effect in the world
now this might seem sort of nitpicky so
why do I think that this difference
between thinking of bottles as sort of a
single black box versus a multi-stage
pipeline matters
um I think that first and foremost this
is sort of a change in our mental model
of what production looks like and it
will affect how we think about building
production grade models we can't build
in a vacuum and we need to have an
understanding of the relationships
between the models that we are training
and the data that flows through them
we're trying to develop a mindset that
starts at the raw data and goes through
all of the components that lead up to
the prediction or the consumption of the
outputs and I think that this is going
to increase you and your team's
productivity by thinking about this as a
system and wasting less time on hacky
solutions that don't really fit what
you're going to need in the end
and I think that
um the other thing is you need to
understand that your what your needs are
if you're going to get a real chance at
solving them properly and this relates
to a different talk that I've given in
the past about solving ml Ops or first
principles
um and so that's what we're trying to do
with this specific problem today so
let's talk about uh first principles
thinking and this is stable diffusion's
interpretation of someone thinking from
first principles
um but in order to take a first
principles approach we basically are
going to discuss our assumptions about
the problem and then break this problem
into the smallest irrefutable pieces and
build a solution from the bottom up with
those pieces
so what are we assuming
um about this problem
first and foremost I'm going to focus on
what I think is the simplest case for
deployment a single model I want to make
it easy to understand the thought
process behind deconstructing this and
it'll be easier to explain in a way that
you can extrapolate to your own special
cases so I know I mentioned that the
deployment process is actually more
complex than this but we're going to
take a simple flow and and I think that
it's going to apply to the more complex
cases but will be easier to learn if you
feel like you have a more complex use
case and you want some help discussing
how to deconstruct it according to the
principles I'm going to show in a moment
you can reach out to me either on
LinkedIn or in the Discord for pi data
afterwards and I'm happy to help
um so what I'm just going to say is if
you remember the more complex
pipeline that I showed earlier imagine
everything just fits within this model
box and that's what we're deploying
last but not least I am going to assume
we are not discussing anything relating
to the uh process of training the model
my assumption is that you have a model
that's already trained and you're just
going ahead and uh working on the the
getting into production
great so after all of that how do we
break the deployment process down into
its constituent components from first
principles so we'll we're going to now
go over the theoretical breakdown and
then I'm going to go over each step and
add recommendations and tips for how to
get started uh with each sub
so we have our model ready and the first
thing we're going to need to do is write
a bit of code some function that wraps
the train model loads it receives the
data and performs a prediction and
returns that prediction as the function
output right and this is pretty
straightforward most of us do this uh
almost as part of the process of
training the model and once you have
this it's great you can now predict
locally from your python shell or
jupyter notebook and that's exciting but
that's obviously not what we're looking
for right now we don't only want to
predict locally or just in the language
in which we wrote the function for that
matter so we're going to need a
universal language in which we can
communicate with the model that we built
which will is going to be the interface
to the real world and it's going to so
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to wrap our model in some
API that can receive a request for an
example a Json file sent over an HTTP
request parse that information send it
to our function and return the
prediction in some other standard format
Js
and once we've done this we can
basically now communicate with our model
in a universal language which is awesome
right
um but it's still running locally and
that's not what we want so we need to
figure out a way for it to be run in
other places or in other words we want
to make sure it doesn't just work on our
machine and this is stable diffusion's
interpretation for the Johnny Depp on
the bench beam
um where they made both uh the people
Johnny Depp
um and the fact that I'm mentioning
Docker here is me kind of breaking the
rules of first principles thinking for
the meme's sake but generally speaking
the next step is to make sure our API is
inside some environment that makes it
portable and able to run wherever we
need it to we can call this step
containerization if we want to adopt
docker's terminology but it doesn't have
to be Docker if that doesn't fit your
needs and the main point I'm trying to
make here is we want a package that
contains the environment code the API
and other requirements that we have so
that we don't care which cloud provider
or machine I'm putting this on it can
just run and once we do that we can
basically we have basically a portable
environment for our model and it can
communicate with the world in a
standardized format and the resulting
communication triggers a function that
returns our model's prediction
so we're almost there
but the last thing that we're missing in
this sort of entire thing is is that
everything should exist someplace where
our consumers or users can use it in
other words we need some infrastructure
to host our container and this usually
means the cloud a magical place where
Anything could happen but it of course
doesn't have to be infrastructure could
be on-prem uh or on an edge device as
well
and once we get done with this last part
we basically can use our model from
anywhere we want we have a universal
language that can trigger it and it
Returns the predictions uh that it has
and so it's basically ready to be
incorporated into our product whatever
that is
so to summarize
um and put everything in one slide right
this is a simple four-step breakdown of
what deployment means taking a first
principles approach and you might say at
this point well this is simple right
like I sort of knew this
um but the reason this is awesome in my
mind is that it means we no longer need
to solve the problem of production or
deployment we have four much smaller
much more tractable problems to solve
and once we solve all of them we're
basically in production
so now that we have all of this laid out
um let's go over a few recommendations
uh for this step for each step rather
including uh the recommended tools
so step one
um and I think that for step one the
default Choice here is always the tools
that you're already familiar with when
it's possible so for most of you this
probably means Python and some
tensorflow Pi torch psychic uh whatever
it is right and this is just assuming
that there are no constraints on the
language you need or the Frameworks that
you need it might be that you have uh to
do this in go or C plus plus for
efficiency's sake or for connecting with
other data processing steps
um which might or might not have sort of
dedicated bindings for the Frameworks
that you've trained the model in
um
the other thing that I think is
important to note is the way you save
your model can affect its future
portability if that's something that you
care about you might want to look at
portability first formats like onnx this
might be especially important if you
deploy to multiple types of endpoints
and more generally as your company grows
you're going to want to converge on sort
of a single or maybe a few processes for
deploying your models and this means uh
somewhere in your pipeline you're going
to want to standardize everything so
exporting to some standard non-framework
specific format is a great way to Future
proof uh your project in that respect
last but not least if you expect to have
additional models deployed in the future
it's worth spending a bit of time
defining which functions need to be
implemented and defining a company or
team-wide class or interface this is
going to improve interoperability in the
future and enable you to build
infrastructure and automation down the
line that will support and be relevant
to Future models
many tools that automate the deployment
process require you to comply with such
a format anyway so it's a good idea to
adopt this mindset early on and this
doesn't usually cost you too much up
front but it can provide a lot of value
later on
okay so now we're at two the recommended
tools for this task can be anything from
uh manual implementation with python
requests all the way to fast API which
is my currently my personal favorite now
all of these are great tools and if you
want to learn how to use one of them you
can basically Google tutorial machine
learning API with X and you'll find
great materials
it is important to note that some model
consumers require non-flexible endpoints
so to give a concrete example there is a
labeling tool that supports machine
learning Model Auto labeling with an
externally deployed model now this tool
requires that the endpoint to be at sort
of some HTTP uh Slash URL model URL
slash predict and it won't accept
anything else so if you have predictions
for example that doesn't work for that
tool now if you're using that tool
you're going to need to make sure that
you implement the predictions uh the way
the proper way and this can be expanded
to the fact that you might need multiple
endpoints for the same functionality if
your data consumers require that even
though of course it's ideal to create a
standard here as well
um and I think there this requires sort
of a small note about authentication
um at this point you need to also
consider what the context for your
deployment is going to be if you have a
distributed microservice architecture
and your model is going to be exposed to
the web you're going to need to spend
time implementing proper authentication
for it
now this is beyond the scope of this
talk but from my experience this is a
glossed over detail that sometimes
surprises people when they're
implementing their path to production
some infrastructure providers have
out-of-the-box support for
authentication but you can also
Implement uh if you need custom
deployments you can also implement this
yourself and again here if you Google
authentication with tool X or
authentication with uh for example fast
API it's going to provide some example
reading uh some example tutorials for
this and I'm going to provide one
specific one that I recommend later on
in this talk
okay so now we're at step three
um so in this case my answer to
recommended tools is of course Docker a
lot has been said and uh as I said about
about it but in the end it's a good idea
to have an understanding of how it works
and how to use it it's very customizable
and even if you use something else it's
probably using Docker under the hood so
a basic understanding is warranted
there are a lot of tools that are
offering a simplified and automated
process that covers sometimes a combo of
step two and three together so they
write the API wrapper and containerize
the the model in one go and they are
awesome
um but it is important to know that
there is a built-in trade-off so the
reason they're able to make an easier
path to manually doing uh uh two and
three is that they make decisions on
your behalf so if you have a very
standard deployment process they are
very likely a good fit but know that for
customization you're probably going to
dive one layer deeper and get into the
nitty-gritty of what is usually Docker
so this isn't a full replacement and I
still recommend having a basic
understanding of Docker nonetheless
okay we're almost at the end so for
infrastructure
um in our final stage I would argue that
we don't really have recommended tools
as much as our necessary deployment
setup and this stage probably has
um constraints like whether or not we're
deploying a microservice endpoint uh
Lambda function or or pipeline stage or
on a user's Edge device so depending on
what you need specifically you're going
to need to adjust sort of the
implementation of this last phase
um an important caveat that at least I
failed a bunch of times before and and
sort of caused me a bunch of misery so
hopefully I'll help you avoid
um is that in all stages
um as well so this applies to step three
and and step two as well you need to
remember that the incoming and outgoing
traffic that is going to your model is
going to pass through all these
additional layers to get to the actual
model function that's doing the
prediction so it's really important to
open the ports or open the paths from
the infrastructure through the container
and to the API
um and this might seem obvious but again
it has caused me unnecessary grief so
hopefully I can help you avoid that and
of course this talk a talk like this
wouldn't be complete if we weren't
talking about gpus
most of the existing infrastructure that
that
um that is built today isn't really
targeted towards machine learning the
first and and foremost priority is just
software workloads and one of the main
things that we need that is dissimilar
from software workloads is a
significantly higher demand for gpus now
working with them is sort of notoriously
more complicated you need to pay
attention to things like Cuda and many
of the tools that I mentioned in the
previous stage sometimes help you uh
that sometimes help you automate step
two and three also assist in the
configuration of gpus within your
environment but you can also find great
content about working with them directly
or via dedicated cloud services like
sagemaker I'm going to provide a piece
of content for this in a moment
so this is basically it we've reached
the end of our journey and we're in
production and I want to end with a few
resources that will help you take the
next step with each uh part of the
process so this QR code is for a Google
doc that basically includes all of the
steps and
um I'm going to share this uh the link
to this Doc in a moment in the chat
um but we have here something for how to
build the API for the machine learning
model how to add authentication how to
use Docker in data science context and
then how to deploy GPU accelerated
applications uh with AWS and docker so
with that thank you very much for
joining my talk I hope it was useful I'm
happy to take questions and you can
follow me on Twitter or LinkedIn if you
like content like this and feel free to
reach out to me again if you think that
your process is a bit different and you
want advice on how this uh sort of
breakdown process works in your case
sharing
thank you thank
you one question and that is yep why do
we need authentication when model is
exposed to the web I'm sure there is an
obvious reason I'm just not aware
yeah so the the first time I stumbled on
this is
um one of the teams that we were working
with basically deployed a machine
learning model
um and the Machine the model was
deployed uh through one system but the
consumers of the model existed uh in
another system so uh they could they the
they had basically
um they had multiple ways to solve this
right but the way that they decided to
solve it is basically to deploy the
model on AWS and open it up to the web
and have the consumers from the
different systems access that uh API
endpoint the problem is it had a
proprietary information so you don't
want to give access to the entire
internet to your model endpoint and so
in that case what they basically needed
to do is they needed to add
authentication to this entire process so
that they can know that the people that
are querying the model can should
actually have access to it and should
receive the responses so that's sort of
the main example I can give
thanks perfect
uh yeah we have a lot of comments saying
thank you it was awesome very insightful
so thank you so much Dean
sure happy to help and yeah I'll be as I
said I'll be on the Discord uh for a
while now if you want to reach out to me
uh via DM or something like that to talk
about more uh complex or specific uh um
cases for deployment and if you have
some uh yeah more questions I'm happy to
answer oh yeah we do we got one more
just now
I will show it what do you think about
project organization a particular file
structure to recommend
sure yeah this is a this is a good
question which I actually am I'm working
on on something
um on this front as well which I'm
hoping will be released pretty soon
um basically I think that the main thing
to remember if if I'm being objective
here is that the important part is to
converge on something and then have it
across the organization and that adds
sort of uh uh a lot of value in in sort
of being able to move between projects
in your organization and understand
what's going on there because you don't
have to relearn the process uh from
scratch
um and the the specific recommendation I
have here is of course like cookie
getter data science I think provides a
really good uh uh starting point
um and I'm working right now on a
project that's sort of a cookie I'm
calling it like Cookie Cutter mlops and
the idea is to add a bit of things that
are more related to production in the
context of machine learning into this
template
um so so so that's sort of the the way
I'm thinking about this but again the
important takeaway here is have decide
on a structure that you think is right
you can use cookie cutter data science
it's great and then make sure that every
project starts from that structure and
that's the best way to set yourself up
for Success uh down the line